I want you guys to take the cast of the
predator and tell me what roles you
would want them to play in the 1987
original guess I'm Carl waters and I
guess Boyd's Arnold trey is tre Scott
great acting chops he should play bill
Duke who is a rarely remember we should
remember bill Dukes performance in that
movie is amazing
you also would think Tracy played Dylan
you know though should play do Jesse
obviously obviously Jesse the body
Ventura
yes broke obviously I have not done
enough push-ups Jesse the body you know
I am I'm a guy the very Shan Shan you
are shame you're Hawkins really all
right I'm sorry you got a dress this is
like which friends character are you
live you would be a great Ahnold Jacob
is Jesse obviously if you're not if I'm
not Jesse then it's Jacob definitely
exactly yeah and have you Jacob can do
some push-ups - Jacob can do some
one-handed push it yes yeah
so it's one-handed push-ups that's not
even a joke that's not even a joke
that's on video mm-hmm I probably be
like camera um forget his name but he's
the guy who loses his arm and he's like
and it's like the complicated hand is
still shooting the gun oh yeah probably
that guy Jacob Jacob would play colonel
I'd like to see Jacob been like like a a
wunderkind Colonel the guy who sends
them on the mission gonna be before they
get on the chopper but he's in right
he's ain't grown up close but he's in
yeah when he's wearing a certain time
that's a three-piece suit with a vast
yeah by the way or he's like sitting on
someone's shoulders and it's like two
people and a good cigar Hennessy God is
like you're going into the jungles of
Guatemala so then who could play Billy
he was great he's my for might be that's
my favorite character i want to play
billy you can play play you can play
Billy you know we'll double cast we'll
double cast I'll put a mustache on Billy
had the big one the big big knife phrase
didn't you have the bowie knife slash
machete I really want to see this
version we should just do the remake